a lot of you really liked my videos
where I talked about the top 10 R
packages that you should know so then I
figured then why not talk about the top
10 python packages you should know well
that's what we're going to do in this
video I'm Richard and this is Richard on
data so let's suppose you're learning
python for the first time when I'm
making this video it's the year 2024 so
I'm sure there's plenty of people out
there for whom that's the case well I
know it can be pretty daunting when you
go open up somebody's script and there's
like 20 packages at the top that they're
importing more often than not though you
really don't have to do that you can
focus on a few fundamental packages
learn those really well and your
abilities to do data science in Python
will accelerate very rapidly and I can
promise you if you learn the 10 packages
that I'm going to go through in this
video you're going to be in great shape
so before I do that take a moment to
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and smash the like button for
the YouTube algorithm now let's get to
it so the first one we're going to start
start with is going to come as a
surprise to absolutely nobody and that's
pandas pandas is the core data
manipulation analysis and data science
library of python and part of the reason
for that is because pandas gives us the
series and data frame objects which are
very helpful for us actually loading
data and getting it into an appropriate
format so we can move on and do more
exciting things with it which pandas
also gives us those capabilities so this
pandas cheat sheet here comes from data
and it's absolutely outstanding and has
pretty much everything you need right
here there's two pages here now on the
left side of the first page we've got
everything around creating data frames
as we move to the right we have things
around changing the structure sorting
reindexing and these are going to be
some of the most important functions in
the whole package things like sort
values sort index reset index and drop
those are super helpful functions
and then as we start moving down you've
got functions for subsetting
observations and variables that should
also be one of the very first things you
focus on getting comfortable with as we
go to the second page we start getting
methods for summarizing and grouping
data value counts describe and unique
shape those are all things you'll
probably use every single day the
grouping stuff at the bottom can take a
little while to get used to so that's
definitely something I recommend
practice practicing a bit to get the
hang of now I recommend pandas as the
first one because it's pretty easy to
pick up and it's also going to help you
to do the most the fastest but another
package that's arguably even more
foundational and this is another one
that will come as a surprise to
absolutely nobody is numpy numpy is a
fundamental package for scientific
Computing and handling large data sets
in Python because it supports
multi-dimensional large arrays and
matrices and gives us functionality for
working with them here's a publicly
available cheat sheet for numpy this one
is created by data camp and this one is
only a one pager so the first section on
the left is all showing us how to create
arrays in particular one function I use
a lot is np. AR range it looks like it's
pronounced a range but it's actually
pronounced a range and then np. random
is useful sometimes as well but then as
we go towards the middle there's lots of
arithmetic and Matrix type operations
and on the right side is some of the
most important stuff all around sub
setting slicing indexing and array
manipulation so definitely good stuff to
get comfortable with and now there's one
function I use all the time that isn't
actually on this cheat sheet that
function is np. wear so that's basically
like an IFL statement that super clean
and easy to use but yeah anyway that's
numpy number three on this list is going
to be another totally unsurprising one
that's matplot lib so matplot lib is an
incredibly powerful and flexible package
that's going to allow us to create and
customize graphs now I don't want to say
you could literally make any possible 2D
plot that you could imagine but with
Matt plot lib it's pretty close so this
is Matt plot lib's official cheat sheet
and to be honest about this one this one
is probably a little difficult for a
beginner to get used to I'd say the most
useful thing here is probably the
starter code at the top where we're
defining figure and axis objects and
then it breaks down the anatomy of a
figure down below it's sort of helpful
to think about a matte plot lib figure
in these components and they're all just
components that we're writing code to
alter so you've got major and minor
ticks title objects on a graph like
lines grip GS and y and x axis here then
we've got a lot of helper lines of code
under this quick reminder section on the
right side see you can do things like
set the x or y limits X or Y labels X or
Y ticks so on and so forth but honestly
my recommendation is just to go to the
matplot lib website look at some
examples see how the pieces of code come
together and then try to create a few
before long you'll get the hang of it
we're going to move on to another
plotting library for number four and
that's Seaborn now actually with Seaborn
it's based on matplot lib and whatever
you do I do also recommend learning
matplot lib because that is really going
to ingrain a lot of fundamentals of
plotting in Python for you but Seaborn
is worth learning too because the syntax
is amazingly succinct and simple and
when you go trying to customize more
complex visualizations it's going to
make your life a lot easier this Seaborn
cheat sheet over here comes from data
Camp again and I think this one's a lot
easier for beginners to get a handle of
compared to the matplot lib one because
it actually gives us some guided
examples so it starts in section one
with loading some pre-built data sets in
the second section we can use the mat
plot lib code to alter the size of the
plot and then the Seaborn code to change
some of the style then as you can see
from section three the code is quite
straightforward you just Define the data
you're using your X and Y AIS and
sometimes any ancillary variables like
this LM plot that changes the Hue using
the species variable and then you're
pretty much good to go then there's
plenty of examples as we move from the
right down of different types of plots
you can make in caborn again very
powerful stuff this combination of mat
plot lib and Seaborn is a must know for
anyone picking a python now the fifth
package here is actually a much smaller
and simpler one but it really is the
unsung hero in a lot of work and that's
datetime so in basically anything with
the possible exception of squl working
with dates and times is painful it's
painful in R and it's painful in Python
too date time though is going to give us
classes for working with dates and times
so whatever it is you're trying to do
whether it's arithmetic or manipulation
or setting up a model date time is going
to to make your life easier now at the
time I'm recording this video I don't
think there's any easy cheat sheet for
date time the way there is for the
others up to this point but the
documentation is pretty quick and easy
to use you can see first you've got a
date method that returns an object with
convenient year month and day attributes
you've got a similar thing for the time
method and then you've got a date time
that puts both of these two things
together into one not to mention you've
got the the now and today methods which
come in handy a lot lastly I don't
really know how to pronounce these but
you've got Str strf time and Str strp
time for going back and forth between
date time and string objects now we're
going to get into some really fun stuff
number six on this list is stats models
now for those of you coming from an R
background you're going to absolutely
love stats models what it's going to do
is give us classes and functions for
running stati itical models and
producing summaries of them and these
summaries are very rlike for lack of a
better term they're very easy to set up
and very clean looking this is another
package that doesn't have a clean easy
cheat sheet like some of the others but
again the documentation is fairly easy
to follow along with it's pretty easy if
we go over here to the ordinary least
squares example so they start by
generating some artificial data
generating an intercept by using using a
column of ones and then fitting an sm.
object down below they use fit and
summary methods and then look at that
output told you if you're used to R it's
going to look pretty familiar and even
if you aren't then this is going to make
it so easy to use for you that you're
not even going to need to use R you have
all of exactly the same output but most
importantly you have all of your
coefficients their standard errors T
statistics and P values in this nice
clean table and this is a pretty quick
example but as you can see from the
contents on the left side there's plenty
of stuff that you can do using stats
models at the time I'm recording this
it's only version
0.15 but it's still extremely reliable
powerful and something that you should
have in your python repertoire there's
no list of python packages that would be
complete without number seven which is
of course the famous psychic it learn
psyit learn is the fundamental machine
learning offering in Python so in it we
get all kinds of tools for your standard
classification regression clustering
algorithms all that good stuff but you
also get tons of tools for the full
machine learning pipeline so data
pre-processing fitting evaluation really
anything that you can need luckily pyit
learn is another one of those packages
which has a nice cheat sheet for it
again this one comes from data camp and
this one from start to end gives us a
really nice workflow at the upper left
we have a super basic compact example
but we can start to add some more to all
these different pieces as we move down
we've got the train test split function
under that we have the fit function at
the bottom the predict and predict proba
functions predict proba gives us the
model's estimated probability of a
particular label so this this is super
helpful and then you've got all these
useful pre-processing methods things
like standardization normalization
encoding categorical features imputing
missing values and on the right side you
have things like confusion matrices or
metrics like mean squared error R squar
score various clustering metrics so you
get the idea you really have everything
you need for most machine learning
pipelines right here with psyit learn
number eight on this list is one of my
personal favorites and that's streamlit
so for those of you who've been
following my channel for a long time you
might know that I'm a big fan of R shiny
there are other options but streamlet is
by far and way my favorite option in
Python for creating sharable web
applications I find this to make
prototyping a lot faster and it can save
you and your audience a ton of time
compared to creating a ton of scripts or
notebooks so this cheat sheet here comes
directly from streamlit you have to do
some scrolling within each of the boxes
to get everything here and honestly
streamlit is another one of those
packages that you're not going to learn
everything just from reading a cheat
sheet you have to try building your own
apps once you do that this stuff will
eventually just come naturally for you
but anyway you have various command line
stuff at the top followed by Magic
control flow and connecting to data
sources the stuff you need for
displaying text and displaying data
follows so you can use st. text st.
markdown st. write you can use st. datf
frame or st. table for data and then
there's all this interactive stuff in
the middle which again the best way to
get a feel for this is to write your own
code or at least go to the gallery and
look at some examples one last thing I
do want to point out are these two
sections on the right for caching data
objects and caching resources if you
start developing an app with multiple
Pages or that generally just has a lot
going on you're definitely going to want
to incorporate these caching decorators
otherwise your app is going to be super
slow we're going to close this list out
with the Beloved neural network packages
so number nine then to No Surprise will
be tensorflow tensorflow is another full
machine learning framework that's going
to help us build and train neural
network models so you can start to get
your feet wet with this a little bit by
using the tensor playground and the link
to that will be in the description but
tensorflow is going to give us the
foundation for the next package and it's
going to be your first go-to for deep
learning tasks and non-trivial neural
network models there's a site out there
called zero to Mastery and it's got some
of the best tensorflow documentation
I've seen so I'll keep this one pretty
quick because some of it's going to be
covered under the next package but you
start with your basic tensor operations
those are going to be the fundamental
building blocks for the rest of what we
do so you're doing basic math and
reshaping them then as you go down you
get into creating layers creating basic
neural network models compiling them
training them evaluating them then as we
go down various data pre-processing
steps and as it keeps going down there's
more functionality around creating more
advanced models Say by using the
functional API so again you've got a
mass framework here that's going to
allow you to perform virtually any step
of a machine learning pipeline
specifically in the context of neural
networks as you may or may not have
guessed by this point number 10 on this
list is Caris so Caris is going to give
us another highlevel neural networks
framework but this one is probably a
little bit more userfriendly and simple
you can rapidly prototype deep learning
models while still having the
flexibility to customize every aspect of
the model that you're building and
technically since tensorflow has
incorporated Caris as its official
highlevel API under the hood when you're
using tensorflow you're essentially
using Caris as well now closing this off
with another one of these super clean
and compact cheat sheets from data Camp
they have one for Caris as well and just
like in the psyit learn sheet sheet they
start with a super strip down basic
example and flesh more stuff out on the
rest of the page there's pre-processing
stuff like one hot encoding on the left
side then in the middle we saw some of
the stuff in the tensorflow
documentation but for your major neural
network types like your multi-layer
perceptrons your CNN and your rnns
you've got methods that you import and
then layers that you can add on top of
your model then on the right side you
can inspect the model summary and get
weights or helpful functions and then as
you go down you can compile these models
fit them evaluate them fine-tune them so
this is yet again another instance where
this stuff may or may not look really
abstract and really you don't totally
get the hang of it until you start
practicing it but Caris is another Super
useful package to have under your belt
and this cheat sheet will be a great
reference for it all right so that's
been 10 python packages that at the time
I'm making this video and probably for
many years to come if you know these
really well they're going to help you to
solve a tremendous number of data
science problems learn and practice the
packages by using the cheat sheets as
resources and just working through some
examples you'll be amazed with how
confident you feel with the Python
language as a whole when you're done so
thanks for watching this video If you
enjoyed it smash the like button if you
didn't enjoy it I suppose you're free to
hit the dislike button as well then
leave me a comment down below and let me
know what you think what's your favorite
python package and anything that you
think I really excluded here then I'll
see you all in the Noto distant future
until then Richard on data